this is my picture of the week it shows
two people at a demonstration
after the attack in orlando who
turn to each other in their grief and
support them and do not
turn away from each other in hate and fear
this picture symbolizes for me the
only right answer to an
attack by
orlando we must not
turn away from each other in fear and hate
exactly what terrorists often
want to do with their
attacks because fear and hate are the greatest threat
to our open free
societies it is my picture of the week because it is a
response to the disgusting attempt
to benefit from donald trump and his followers
from the terrible
attacks for his xenophobic
exclusionary policies
i will not stop going to
gay bars and dancing and i
will not stop
fighting for equal rights for muslims